auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine klebrige sauerei
das mischen der haselnuss creme endet in
einem zünftigen schlamassel
bei den amerikanischen traum leben
marina und mike wollen in florida ein
waffe restaurant eröffnen aber
keine heißen waffeln ohne
fähigkeitszeugnis
400 tiere und 240 hektar land an der
atlantikküste
für diesen bauernbetrieb verlässt
familie visa die heimat die erwachsenen
kinder bleiben in der schweiz ihre
kleine herde nehmen sie mit
soft wenn erich auf fähren schafften um
die herrschaft in
frankreich erhoffen sich die bauern mehr
unternehmerische freiheit
späte liebe eva dunkle und philips
weiter matti wollen in der toskana ein
agriturismo betreiben die italienische
variante für ferien auf dem bauernhof
800 olivenbäume pflanzen sie an doch an
einer stelle scheint der boden
unfruchtbar
[Musik]
florida auswanderin marina mara ist
erleichtert sie hat eine bedeutende
hürde geschafft
das weiß hier ihr blut geschwitzt kann
man muss da ja nadja und
betete bestanden nicht und jetzt und ich
denke so wichtig wie die tat
[Musik]
monatelang haben mike und marina diesen
tag herbeigesehnt den tag an dem der
umbau ihres waffe restaurants endlich
abgeschlossen sein wird
[Gelächter]
pünktlich eingetroffen die letzte
dekoration fürs restaurant
[Applaus]
vorschriftsgemäß aus plastik
wegen der pandemie kam der umbau ihres
waffel shops kaum voran die
jungunternehmer verloren viel zeit und
geld
doch diese frustrierenden monate sind
endlich geschichte morgen findet das
sogenannte soft opening statt die
generalprobe zur richtigen eröffnung
eingeladen sind influenza presseleute
bekannte und nachbarn
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
marine und mikes american dream nimmt
endlich wieder fahrt auf
unterwegs in der toskana die
kindergarten lehrerin eva doodle hat
frühlingsferien
ev hat gemischte gefühle denn etwas
grundlegendes hat sich geändert eva und
philipp sind kein paar mehr bereits seit
wochen vor ort im agriturismo ist
gutsverwalter phillips weiter matti er
bereitet ifas ankunft vor
[Musik]
ob sie genau das hat wähle was neue
zurück und weiß
aber dass wir zu werden wo sie ja dann
auch nicht
fertig lustig
die beiden teilen das bett nicht mehr
die initiative für die trennung ging von
ifa aus
sie haben ja eigentlich mehr oder
weniger homies bestand der chor kopf das
bezirk mit mir
so ist das leben eben
trotzdem wollen sie an ihrem
auswanderungs projekt festhalten aus
liebe soll nun eine freundschaftliche
geschäftsbeziehung werden
mit
philipp lebt im hauptgebäude sogar
ich habe mich dorthin exportiert mit dem
mit dem ding
durchschaubaren du hast du aber ein
komisches gleich das ist nichts problem
aber ich kann jetzt auf der anders sieht
das so gemacht
wie erwartet eva will ihr eigenes bett
[Musik]
parteien eine torhüter morgan de france
weiter die jetzt oder was du
hast du sicher dass du
deine das ist jetzt zum zweiten mal
schauen und am magic bringt es mit der
struktur
naja und höflichsten carl chance gesehen
aber du hast es ja quasi ohne
chance
[Musik]
in frankreich auf dem hof lah sowie
geht's ums große geld 400 tiere der
futter bestand und die
landwirtschaftlichen maschinen wechseln
heute ihren besitzern
die verkäufer samt makler und die visa
haben sich im hofeigenen büro versammelt
die vorbesitzer von lee sowie die
gebrüder rung und ihre familien hatten
den hof während jahrzehnten geführt
sandro der studierte ökonom ist
überzeugt hier in frankreich kann
endlich gewinnbringend bauern dafür
verkauften die visa es ihren 18 hektar
großen hof in der schweiz
[Musik]
was für
eine million euro noch nicht inbegriffen
sind die gebäude das wohnhaus und das
grundstück
[Musik]
jobs so schnell hat man nun jesus in
block tode kraft
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
beim notar werden am nachmittag auch hof
und land überschrieben eine weitere
beträchtliche summe wird dabei den
besitzer wechseln
[Musik]
gutsverwalter philipp ist zufrieden sein
rasentraktor hält was er verspricht
[Musik]
trotz ferien ifa ist eine
frühaufsteherin und immer voller elan
nun bremst der linke arm ihren
gestaltungswillen vor einigen wochen hat
sie ihn im kindergarten gebrochen
also was mich natürlich dreht sich das
jetzt will ich ein einarmiger bandit bin
einfach nur froh machen oder machen das
ist so dass man das
tut mir nur mäßig gut weil ich könnte
jetzt so richtig oder thema für
zähneputzen und machen und tun
es war der große crew zur pensionierung
dann wenn es andere gemütlicher nehmen
warten eva und philipp ein abenteuer ein
agriturismo in der toskana dafür war
immer bereit ein haus in der schweiz zu
verkaufen
[Musik]
doch auf die große begeisterung folgte
die ernüchterung das projekt schritt
voran und eva plagten immer mehr zweifel
die gemeinsame aufgabe ließ sie nicht
stärker zusammenwachsen
gegensätzlichkeiten einst anziehend
irritierten eva immer mehr
[Musik]
und sie kam zum schluss dass sie beide
viel mehr trennt als ein
hat dass ganz viele baustellen
und ich bin einfach so
also ich bin einfach ich habe schon
immer vor von gesagt habe ich bin
einfach ich bin sehr dominant ich bin
nicht
und wie es eigentlich offen mal
so in
das loch mit mit mit dem vorschlaghammer
oder oder edi business masters radikale
salbe und es ist
schwierig etwas inneren hier will ich
weiß immer sehr gerne habe und was ich
gut und wenn ich nicht weiß dann mit
regelmäßig
geschäftlich bleibt alles beim alten eva
die kapitalgeber in pendelt während der
ferien in die toskana
philipp der gutsverwalter treibt das
unternehmen voran
also ich weiß es nicht aber es
ist meine ich sehe du hast du sehr viel
witz anderem an dem ganz anders ist es
ist danke kurz konzept und das wie gut
die hat sich auch das ist sehr hoch für
mich nichts machen als dass man
eigentlich vorher dank hat er's bin ich
da und daran ist dass man ja machen das
ist nichts problem das ist nicht
ich denke das ganze projekt ist es
aufgesetzt das ist kein grund muss das
bayerisch oder sollte damit man das kann
kann realisiert vor dem heck sich das
haben wir das bietet sie an weitermachen
[Musik]
euro
monatelang kam marina und mikes projekt
nur schleppend voran zum schluss muss es
nun umso schneller gehen
juni
noch schnell ihr angebot auf den
bildschirm liefen
filmklasse shakes und drinks
mike vereins schreiner dann jahrelang
polizist und nebenbei tätowierer so war
sein einkommen monat für monat gesichert
forscher hohe geschlossener fonds nun
haben die letzten monate gezeigt nichts
ist sicher und die zukunft ungewiss das
sagten ihr größtes komisch wie das kommt
sehr viel geld mehr investiert das muss
eigentlich mal danke
zusätzlich
die strom installation wird heute einer
abschließenden prüfung unterzogen
[Musik]
die letzte hürde vor der eröffnung einen
neuen bushof der charmante brite
schaffte die herren also priester
wie sie eröffnet würde zwanziger was
jetzt zwar nicht hoffen
wenn ich mit einem controller wie sie
nun gott nicht
bereits auf einkaufstour ist marina
begleitet von eve staub auch eve ist in
die usa ausgewandert und partner
derselben gastro kette seit einem jahr
hat er seinen eigenen waffen shop in
houston
[Musik]
zur unterstützung der eröffnung hätte
eigentlich jemand vom deutschen
hauptgeschäft in die usa reisen wollen
doch corona verunmöglichte flüge in die
usa
lief aus houston sprang ein
nicht liefern lassen selber einkaufen
das ist günstiger
zurück zu mike die inspektion dauert
noch immer an es ist kaum zum aushalten
[Musik]
doch alles nur halb so weht der
bauleiter gibt das ok
einmal mehr geschafft
[Musik]
alles unterschrieben und notariell
beglaubigt die schweizer können den hof
lah sowie ihr eigen nennen und
einrichten
morgen muss doch plötzlich kommt
20 jahre ist es her dass sich die beiden
in einer disco in zürich sackte ration
kennengelernt haben bald war ihnen klar
sie wollen ihr leben gemeinsam
verbringen
alles war perfekt und die beiden
heirateten
doch ihre liebesgeschichte hat einen
bruch
ich alles erlebt haben
zwischen
der
liga und ist genau wie das gar nicht ja
das normal mit 20 mit lauten scheide und
dann hier lautet das projekt bleibt man
sich nun erneut
[Musik]
tatsächlich die beiden ließen sich nach
sechs ehejahren scheiden
doch gerade mal zwei jahre später
verliebten sie sich erneut und
heirateten zum zweiten mal
nicht verzogen
champagner ist an diesem abend ein muss
mit dem vorbesitzer patrice und seiner
freundin marie lehn wollen sie heute auf
ihr neues lebenskapitel anstoßen
wo
[Musik]
massa marittima
die zürcher sind auf einkaufstour
eva weiß was sie will und philipp weiss
wo sie es finden kann
vorhang stangen für die ferienwohnungen
einrichten und kreativ sein darauf
versteht sich liefern
philipp ganz gutsverwalter bringt die
bescheinigung dass sie eine italienische
firma besitzen so können sie gewisse
ausgaben steuerlich absetzen
hallo rein
ja das glaube ich das von jp morgan
moment ich morgen und auch für die 110
gegenwärtig
bedingungen wiederum ich weiß dann muss
man
also da kann ich mir nach cottbus
der versuch trotz trennung gemeinsam
ihren traum vom eigenen agriturismo zu
leben scheint auf gutem wege zu sein
[Musik]
die latte
ok
[Musik]
ich denke mir bei mir der song jetzt
um eine neue form von mit dem und
ich würde mal so sagen ja
derselbe behälter voller
kraft und mehr als
14 ich finde das einfach es ist so
schlicht ab 17 politik für mich sehr
und wenn wir das jetzt trotzdem große
gedenkens nimmt und dann ins schöne frau
gemacht und dann
mit ganz viel
saniert das spannendste entspannen
und wer das ist
[Musik]
tampa in florida heute um 17 uhr ist das
soft opening die generalprobe der
eröffnung die schweizer am content ale
place haben kaum geschlafen zu nervös
sitzt
[Musik]
und nach athen oder hunde kontakt
macht
umhin den china kümmert sich heute die
nachbarin
[Musik]
weil katte bis spät in die nacht
gearbeitet und war vor tagesanbruch
wieder im laden
für marinas zertifikat hat er den
geeigneten platz gefunden
auch aus houston angereist sind die
waffel profis chiara und ihr jüngerer
bruder nico sie sind ives kinder
heute erteilt marina und mike die
wichtigste lektion dass teig hören
jeden tag übel wird eine vom
franchise-geber eigens zusammengestellte
gewürzmischung beigegeben
das ist korrekt
[Musik]
rühren mit dem bürger so einfach wie das
ausschaut ist es dann doch nicht
marina lernt die redaktion
[Musik]
von oben bis unten mit haselnuss creme
vollgespritzt zum glück ist marina in
einer viertelstunde zu hause
[Musik]
sandro besitzer und schiffe auf dem hof
ist herrschen neue regeln tagwache ist
eine stunde früher
patrice rudow ist nun sein mitarbeiter
statt um halb sieben wird neu um halb
sechs gemolken
nun als angestellter muss der einstige
hofbesitzer patrice sant roos neuerungen
mittragen
früher melken ist nur eine der
änderungen auf dem hof
[Musik]
ja sehen wie komisch angelogen
die stahlaktie respektiv geht da gar
keine diskussion wenn ich etwas will
dann will ich das ist
also die sitzfläche bewusst dass wir
dafür den schritt macht und
die schweiz aus dem kanton soziologe
schweigen aus dem dorf also respekt
das ist
ja und ich glaube wir würden die spitze
des landes lachte und lachte der
definierten und schritt aber ich komme
aber super und es funktioniert und dann
gegen die freut das hatte ich mir
leichter
[Musik]
cavalli
auch der kleinste visa hat heute einen
großen tag sein erster schultag in
frankreich dann kam nach visas zweiten
hochzeit zur welt
geheime stift außer jeder einzig stifter
ihnen wird auch geschrieben aber
wirklich jeder
es wird einfach alles geschrieben ja und
sogar klinik
und der tisch unter leitung und
imtech hat mit da hat man rucksack
jetzt duschen dies zu kontrollieren und
das fleisch war die station
das sind stabiler und david hier doch
da vorne in luxor
[Musik]
neue schule neue gespanne und alles auf
französisch
weiteren kaum französisch spricht haben
die eltern ihn vorerst in einer
privatschule angemeldet
[Musik]
sechs ferienwohnungen wollen die beiden
zürcher künftig in ihrem abi turismo
anbieten um als agriturismo zu gelten
müssen sie landwirtschaft betreiben
philipp ata 4 800 olivenbäume
angepflanzt
[Musik]
doch an einer stelle ihres heims scheint
der boden unfruchtbar
dieser flecken hatte zu diskussionen bei
der vertragsunterzeichnung geführt
was mich erstaunt ist dass der robert
also hat ohne dass man etwas nimmt
lass
nach
das ist ganz
verschieden ist
die beiden wollen wissen was mit dem
boden los ist und nehmen proben eva will
diese in der schweiz untersuchen lassen
von bloßem auge ist nichts
beunruhigendes zu erkennen
[Musik]
jetzt an dass man mich und waren dann
der winter sich komisch
an verschiedenen orten dann noch es
[Musik]
ja ich glaube ich habe genug
zehn minuten vor dem opening die nächste
panne
was ist deutsch das würde zum beste dame
rasch und über der rechtsprechung gilt
auch und gerade für
die schachtel nur auf die anderen stelle
die zweifel und an ihre fans der
erfahrene sprint ruhe in die situation
minute
[Musik]
sich noch einmal so richtig herzen bevor
es losgeht
[Musik]
sehr schön
marilen hat alexandra unter die fittiche
genommen sie soll den wichtigsten markt
der gegend kennenlernen
alle maschinen
okay
das handy nun ist sie seine augen auf
salzburg
der markt des städtchens school
sowieso als besitzerin von einem der
größten höfe der umgebung will alexandra
das angebot kennen hier findet sie käse
und joghurt die mit milch von ihrem hof
produziert worden sind
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
alexandra ist froh um marie lanes
unterstützung
das ist spannend weil das stück folgt
ist ein herzensguter mensch bin ich
wirklich glaube ich wäre überfordert und
würde mit einem
attraktiven mieter schützen vorteil dass
sie wäre so hilft schweizer hat
verstanden
[Musik]
zurück nach seinem latin schulschluss 14
für das styling nominiert
[Musik]
wie soll
ich mir das
okay das
interesse
[Musik]
wenigstens
ein gelungener tag sowohl für die mama
als auch für ihren job
weiter läuft
kurz nach 5 eröffnet mike zum ersten mal
den waffel shop
alle sind parat auch ihre vier
studentinnen die sie für den anlass
angestellt haben
werden die nachbarn die bekannten die
presseleute kommen kommen die influenza
die influenza tier auf den sozialen
medien vor allem die offizielle
eröffnung promoten sollen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
damit machst du ja genau 11
[Musik]
ein braunes oder schwul der schwarzen
geschrieben
und zum ersten mal serviert mike eine
waffel als eigenständiger unternehmer
nach all der aufregung und sorgen die
gäste sind da und noch wichtiger die
waffeln kommen gut an auch bei den in
friends an
[Musik]
er ist noch weit
in der nächsten folge sind erst der
gäste eben agriturismo
es regnet kaum das wasser ist knapp
und wir haben praktisch bewegt das heißt
wenn wir noch warten die jungen
olivenbäume leiden nun soll eva weiter
geld ins unternehmen schießen
jetzt brauchen wir meinen
brunnenwasser hand mit seinem freund vor
der bank bin ich das für mich kein hotel
stress sequenzen eines automaten ist
jetzt aber fasst prof dann habe ich als
problem in frankreich ist die saison in
vollem gang vater und sohn spannen
zusammen
[Musik]
bis industrien ziehen
der waffel shop fordert mike und marina
mehr als gedacht
stress und im land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten lernt mike das us-institut
kennen comdirect irgendwie kann ich
wesentlich
zielstrebiger
[Musik]
muss ich die gerne willkommen
auf und davon mit der mobile
versicherungen und vorsorge